hey guys how's the guy used to seem
welcome back to another unboxing video
and I'm not sure what's in this box I
have some sort of an idea but I never
asked for this I don't I have absolutely
no idea what's actually inside of it it
said it's from zag though they make
protective screens for phones and cases
and all kinds of things to basically
protect your phone from destruction and
clearly they must have got the memo that
I have a problem and a barking dog might
be wrong let's open it up whoa this is
like a super nice fancy box this looks
like something too good to be in my
hands not for sure what the hook
I sure know a little bit this is
incredible did I ever seen I'm
going to I don't want to do this but I'm
going to have to take this apart to see
how they did this because this is just
freaking amazing
this is absolutely absolutely the
coolest thing ever this is not sponsored
by the way I now have to disclose when
things aren't sponsored because
apparently some new station was saying
that I was getting paid to do all these
unboxing videos and I was like well
that's funny because all of those things
that you said that I did that I didn't
write hashtag add-on I didn't write that
because I purchased them myself and any
time anybody sends me something I let
you guys know but my god is this so cool
so looks like we have two different
cases a mayor for the new Samsung Galaxy
s8 and this is pretty crazy because I am
getting one tomorrow with the time
recording this video I don't actually
have it yet so I'm going to cut from
this video of the unboxing to me trying
this out on ESA so welcome back the s8
unboxing is officially up and now it's
time to try out these screams I look
like these are for the s8 which is good
I do have the s8 plus which is a limit
I'm going to be using so looks like my
sister is going to get herself a nice
little curved protective screen on her
phone so these are like a curved glass
and there's two different versions so
two slides Kay friendly you can use this
with a case oh and this one you can use
metallic case I'm still surprised at the
size comparison of these two because
there's really and there is a difference
but it's still it's a good size both of
them are good size let's check these out
these are curved just fit those sexy
curves Wow application toolkit located
underneath tray
usually really bother putting these on
but it looks like this is a pretty
official thing I'm not sure if she's
going to want to see the case or not
Wow put this on because it looks more
futuristic getting the treatment today
buddy don't expect this all the time
this is in like some super futuristic
like vacuum packed fuel so I put it in
this one peel the clear area okay guys
this is I'm not good at this cough
putting these things on mmm alright
that's lined up started from the bottom
over here looks like she's on fire I
think I probably did it wrong don't
listen to my tutorial watch the real
tutorial that's what I'm going to say do
not use a squeegee around the edges of
the device okay good to know
you definitely didn't do the best job
ever there's still a little bit of
bubbles right here but as I press on
them they actually do seem to start
coming out so I do a face I have faced
if this will work itself out aunts my
sister's gone so sorry I just can't
believe this slop this is so crazy they
even give you a charger so that you can
charge the block I'm so sorry that I
have to I have to open this up and see
what is under here because I'm super
serious this is the coolest thing I've
ever seen
I'm so sad oh wow okay so this is all
separate pieces I don't want to take it
apart but I have to I know how you work
Oh quiet royalty-free
[Applause]
Wow we're inside one side here we go
it's got a batter in here this makes me
tilt that I'm sorry to ruin this person
this is hella worth here's all the
buttons they're each connected to this
little circuit board here here's our
battery and this is the LCD screen back
here that's a little speaker right there
so if it's down as close and I'm like
well I'm open I think I might've broken
and I want to destroy it anymore cover
it back up oh here there we go
it's just like you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]